tout en cours d'exécution maintenant ne mo
flic pas plus vous os [ __ ] de boîte de vache
ne me laisse pas secouer ta vie oh mon dieu
pense que tu reviendras un jour sais ce que
personne ne revient papa pourquoi tu peux
ils ont inondé un tas de villes quand  ils
descendent la rivière, c'est pourquoi ils appellent cette
rivière perdue dès que la dernière ville est
noyée, un sort maléfique a été jeté sur la
rivière perdue, c'est pourquoi tout cet endroit a l'impression
d'être sous l'eau - je sais que
j'aimerais rester dans la maison faire  ça te dérange si je
demande pourquoi j'ai deux garçons et c'est notre
maison tu es une très belle femme qu'est-
ce que c'est c'est le
travail c'est vérifié
travail tu le laisses partir et
si quelque chose arrivait nous devions
partir demain viendriez-vous bébé
la seule façon de briser le sort
cela apporterait la paix au serveur
vous